the four levels of saying you you money
that was kind of the first level it's a
meme but it's also a truth there's an
amount of wealth that you can achieve
when typical restrictions and
conventions don't really apply to you
anymore and then Freedom there are no
restrictions on where you can travel to
and when and for how long you don't need
to show up to work on time or work at
all another level the you family a lot
of fathers that I've spoken to have told
me about how their priorities were
completely changed upon starting a
family and all of the previous status
games that they used to play seemed
quite Petty because the admiration and
the gamesmanship that they used to play
in order to impress people in power or
those with status seemed juvenile fourth
type of saying you which is you Fame
winning the existing game so well that
you are no longer at the mercy of it
example that was used was Rachel
mccadams doesn't have social media
you're so ubiquitous you're so well
known that your Fame carries itself and
you don't need to any longer Play The
Fame game